nein nicht alle tiere die luft gesprengt
kann auch noch wesentlichere welle
heraus diesen sofort wieder ende bereit
um apfel
wann sind sie sofort wieder inter bereit
wenn sie ein stück gras gefressen
hier sind krass viele schafe so acht
stück auf einem haufen passieren hier
sehen und zombie ist tot
ich habe sind wir schon wieder zu doof
mir zu folgen killen sich gegenseitig
weiß ich den hang runter werfen
ich kann mir gut vorstellen
du läufst sofort alle anderen heute sich
hinter dir ja zum kotzen ist dass ihr
lancom mit geld das eine schaaf muss
jetzt zurücklassen weil wir nicht
versucht das zu holen völlig zwei andere
ich meine farben hier alter bis sechs
schafe sind hier hinter mir
100 leute das wird ein schwieriger weg
weg da sie noch in der schafe jetzt
fallen sie alle im pool rheine jetzt
finde ich die ganzen schaffenslust ich
kann genau nachvollziehen was ihr macht
obwohl ich gar nicht dafür soll ist was
gut zum zu sein ich weiß das ganz genau
sie machen die fallen alle im pool
reinalter in welchem pool und dann so
eine kur an komik höher
hmm es soll mit kommen auf einmal
fokussiert sich keiner auf mich hatte
ich hab doch lieber nein nicht nicht
brennen und ich bin so doof oder schafe
die sehen in ihnen feuer rein gelaufen
wie saturn arena immerhin haben sie mir
gebratenes fleisch gegeben da durchaus
schafe kühe
also ich dachte schon ein scharfes thema
neues thema das betrifft wahrscheinlich
alle von uns ein bisschen das thema von
daniel also mich würde es interessieren
wieviel zeit man für so im alltag hier
dinge hat wie freunde treffen mal zur
mona auf zudem im sport mann und so
weiter als sechs player als youtube weil
er so viele videos macht und so weiter
ich meine zum beispiel spart er täglich
mehrere videos raus ich luke
wahrscheinlich auch ich auch mindestens
1 natürlich mal mittlerweile zwei videos
am tag habe ich mir so als höchst links
gesetzt weil ich finde quandt qualität
ist besser als quantität
also habe ich mir solche neuen leitfaden
gesetzt und also bei mir ist es so ich
nehme am wochenende auf also jetzt ist
ja gerade wochenende wo wir das
aufnehmen
dann nämlich eigentlich immer fast alles
offen in der woche versuche ich jetzt zu
unter zu vermeiden menschen ins netz
schoss und dann habe ich in der woche
ich lasse dann halt auch am wochenende
hoch oder über die schulzeiten dann habe
ich in der woche in der woche richtig
viel zeit für schule oder sport weil
wenn man dann teilweise bis halb fünf
oder fünf hochschule hat den du kennst
das ja auch dann hat man nach halt nicht
mehr so viel zeit für freizeit usw ist
einfach so also ich habe in hamburg ist
zu töten
ich habe noch drei vier wochen frei und
dann beginnt zu studieren
genau also ich bin jetzt offiziell
student ich habe schon mal aus weiß was
studierst du deine richtung informatik
also ich wollte ja eigentlich ich habe
nicht den studiengang bekommen den ich
mir gewünscht hatte aber deshalb was
hättet ihr denn gewünscht secret sag mal
bestimmt sogar ein motto das die heimat
studieren da sind wir wieder bei lukas
möchte astronaut studieren astronauten
klar wie schwer das ist die scheiß curie
beschwert weil du immer so richtig
langsam gehen musst ja und hier sind so
viele schlachten die man mir ich hab
gerade eins zwei drei vier fünf schafe
eine kuh und vier hühnchen hinter mir
auch so viel ich gar nicht ich hab heute
die hühnchen alter aber nach ein riegel
geschoben
ich habe so ein holzbedarf heute wieder
solo
er kann aber dennoch gefallen heute
wieder welche verloren da oben kommt mir
dir banausen wenn man sie einmal
verloren und dann wollen wir auch
manchmal nicht wiederkommen ja du guckst
die an mitglied um die wollen einfach
nicht
es ist ja schuld ist eine abholzung der
regenwälder sparks baars werner rohlfs
park eine horde hier scheint es wird
nacht kranke das schaffe ich nie im
leben den akku mehr zu mir hin
hier ein paar knapp hinter mir ich wie
heute
ich sehe es besser aus das kann ich
nicht zu lange dauern weil durch
schätzchen schätzchen schätze rhein-main
rief ein dass die er so lange brauchen
dort brauchen sie online jetzt ist hier
so ein scheiß wasser teilweise die
freunde rhein schubsen sie uns
gegenseitig da rein
ich habe die vermutung dafür auch schon
mal mehr schafe in der märkte ich
brauche jetzt eine klare donnerstag doch
noch zwei mehr alltägliche 7 ich bin den
höhle gefallen alle alle tiere mit mir
dass das wasser würde er kann seine
session 1 geblieben gerade ich versuche
die man irgendwie raus zu kriegen alter
das ist richtig schwer jetzt schon 3er
ausgang
nein kommt noch mitkommt mit herr wo
sind die ganzen anderen schafe hinab die
warten da oben der coach auch mit roger
zedi alle blöd nicht erlaubt bin schon
beim fluss wo wir herkommen
scheiße alter richtig verpackt ich sehe
zwar alle häuser und so aber ganzen bin
ich ein viele zombies ich sehe unser
haus wo wir dass die ersten acht
übernachtet haben in der höhle den
richtern ein ich hab ein schaf verloren
dann müsst ihr relativ nah am mann
ich habe das gefühl gleich irgendwelche
zombies oder irgendwas von hinten an
kommen und mich darum töten egal drei
streichen erstmal haupt aufwärmen 2 ich
habe auch angst vor zombies gerade ich
sehe ein
ich habe mein haus kommen sie mit
bestimmten sich gleich auch irgendwo ein
video mit voll langweilig werden ich
glaube ich mag einen größeren part trotz
die ganzen auch noch nein die spinne tut
nämlich gerade noch zwei schläge und ich
bin tot markt noch einen schlag ich bin
tot doch ein stark und ich bin tot
nein alle tiere die luft gesprengt
leiden fast alle tiere in die luft
gesprengt fast alle daran dass ich sein
wird ich bin aus und fast das denn was
das für das so er war so war das bei mir
ich hab keine ahnung wo ihr wart ich hab
euch nur schreien gehört die ganze zeit
hier war das alte sachen die alle tiere
sind fast tot
ich weiß echt nicht wo das ist fakt
nicht tut alter das ist auch wieder soll
die kapelle zwei skelette stehen hier
echt musstest finden
es war auf jeden fall an so einem fluss
kommt mit wo ist meine ganz auf
weckermann kacke ja stimmt online was
man nicht alles für so ein paar
verpackte schafe tut nur so viel xp
verloren also 100 falls ich tröste ich
habe und gegen alle aufgenommen und da
ist mit perfektem hauses in meinem
schönen fein schnieken häuschen auf
einen krieg und grund im keller
ich kenne ich halt mich auch in der
ersten staffel irgendwo immer zu mir
selbst ich hole jetzt dieses eine spiel
wenig ich hatte so viele tiere alter ist
nicht so an wenngleich nicht mehr
sprinten gleich sind meine ganzen sachen
weg weiß wie viel ich hatte scheiße
marat ist scheiße das war scheiße
unglaublich wolle
ich hatte ich hatte ich hatte tnt ich
hatte übels viel tiefe tot als egal
wollen wenn ich hinterher weinen leben
geht weiter auf ihr glaube ich irgendwo
ich glaube hier irgendwo ja da sind sie
gut und kripo jetzt alle freuen und die
geistige und wie viele tiere sind da
noch jene welche nicht viele also
relativ weil ich nicht so viel fünf
schafe
ich nehme die schafe erst mal mit in
meinem haus ich habe sogar alles wieder
bekommen ich nehm ich hinter mir
die spinne ich hasse dich hatte ich
hasse dich ist es sogar genau die
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich und kriegt alles war
vielleicht solltest du deine mac os x
ausleuchten nein schrieb alter lasse
körper
jetzt die letzten vier schafe die noch
leben dort komplett müssen wir inhalt
von mehreren kommt ihr schreit hier du
auch mit scheiß jetzt kommt ein scheiß
zombie schon wieder einzige was von
meiner heute noch übrig ist von zwei
schafe wieder weich hat inzwischen alles
mögliche ich hatte noch so hühner und
solide aussichten können alles aber man
kommt mit deine blöden 100 nerven helfen
die iss dome ist man kann ich das
erschwert wechseln weil dann die stiere
weg sind all das soll tafelladen wie
lange dauert es noch bis zum tag sind zu
blöd durch eine tür zu laufen oder was
man mag sein
hast du schon so ein zwinger oder sowas
nach aber damit dass vw in gr so zum
tier einen stock
nein ich habe aus versehen ist scheiße
gewechselt jetzt folgen die man niemals
nie mit comics komm komm komm du siehst
doch wohl das feixen hallo muss er
mitkommen ich gehe drängen sie einfach
rein ja eins drin
das andere ist auch drin sehr gut kommt
mir nach unten
schön schön brav so und hier bleibt
erstmal genau hier schafe und zwei kühe
gut ich brauche ganz schnell in zwingern
ja spinnen weg mit ihrer halter alter
alter mit komm jetzt freue ich sie mir
nicht gibt's doch nicht machen ich wette
der zwingers gleich wieder kaputt
jetzt folgen mir drei immerhin 4 und co
und ein kuh und unten sind ja wo die
ware herkommt zu hören
es geht nicht nein nein nein nein nein
nein
noch 13 er noch hat nicht nur 4
das nun scharf drauf gegangen lobby das
jetzt ja aber bitte schon krass was
sonst passiert ist ja verdammt zombie in
der house schafe ja du musst ausleuchten
hey ich hab hier schokolade und im auto
noch viel mehr vorderseite mit meinem
auto ich hab da was für dich ich zwar
keine solltest du genau jetzt werde ich
dann mit einem haus mit lepra dazu
bereit wenn ich keine ressourcen haben
dann geht das nett wenn ihr creative
modell da wäre schon längst fertig ich
habe jetzt so geschaffen
irgendwie auch ein schaf und der mond
auch es wird schon etwas tag mit com
hallo hallo hallo ich solche ausdrücke
junge tier einfach nicht mitkommen
wollen jetzt
einfach anhalten jetzt sei sie sogar
schon mein haus und sparks nahmen kurz
glaube ich habe schon dinge gebaut
so stelle ich möchte erst das schaf
möchte irgendwie erstmal des unbekannten
das versprochen ihn nicht schon wieder
ich hab das geht doch nicht gut aus die
schafe vorgehen nicht gut aus das dann
kommt irgendwie so sprenger
stadtmusikanten
wir bleiben da beide drin ihr blöden
teile man ihr keine theoretischen ihr
könnt nicht mitkommen weil ich noch eine
dinge brauche was brauchst du ja so ich
brauche auch ganz ganz coole stelle
sofort gebaut gar nicht cool
das parkbad in ordnung auf mich immer zu
beleidigen
du bist doof es war voll gibt es fast
gar nicht gut du brauchst nicht gut
kommt mit komm mit kam es damit wohl
dass andere dna mit den tieren hierhin
mit tiere
hallo naja jetzt nur noch 34
jetzt sind erst einmal fressen hallo ja
angucken kannst du nur einmal im grunde
immer noch nicht nehmen ich schubse es
jetzt einfach dahin habt zufällig kohle
irgendwo ja ich habe ein ganz bisschen
zumindest aber er passt ja hatte ich
musste nur gerade kann ich nicht
wechseln was jetzt folgen sie dir auch
noch jetzt kannst du den kohle geben
die uhr laufen kohle deine folge mir
jetzt komplett ohne follower dingens so
viel wie es gehe ich brauch fackeln habe
ich nicht nur was den öfen die beiden
folge nicht nur die musst du irgendwie
hinkriegen
vier stück liegen noch okay die ist gut
diese disco danke
hartes brot semmeln